Now that we've discussed it from different visual
cues and different data types, as well as the
scales to use for those data types, why
don't we circle back to making graphs with ggplot
and try to do something a bit more advanced. This time, we'll want to write a
function lineplot_compare, that will rad in a CSV file called
hr_by_team_year_sf_la.csv. This file contains 3 columns - yearID, HR,
and teamID, which represent the total number of
home runs hit each year by either the San
Francisco Giants or the LA Dodgers. Why don't you
produce a visualization comparing the total home runs hit
by year for the 2 teams. Note that to
differentiate between multiple categories on the same plot in
ggplot, we can pass color in with the other
arguments to aes rather than in our geometry functions.
For example we could say ggplot data aes xvar, yvar, and then
color=catetory_var This should help you to make this chart. Your code goes here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]